he won the Mr Universe contest when he
was 20 and the mr. Olympia contest seven
times he is worth hundreds of millions
of dollars he's been an athlete actor
entrepreneur director model and
politician he's Arnold Schwarzenegger
and here are his ten rules for success
he's the goal and whatever it takes to
get there I would do
so I was doing my daily work cleaning
the guns and going to the shooting range
margin 20 miles a day and rolling around
up hills with weapons running at 5:00 in
the morning with heavy combat boots and
all of this stuff and then everyone just
almost drops dead at night
he's totally exhausted I worked out
three hours and got up early in the
morning again to do my situps and the
push-ups and my chin-ups there was a
clear conflict the dilemma because the
lifting was not a traditional sport for
them they didn't like the idea they
didn't even have the equipment I had to
go and figure out every way possible the
two dips between chairs or to the bar
across two chairs and to upset down
rowing everyone would say this is the
wrong direction that I'm going or I'm in
a dream world and I'm useless
whatever it was I said I'm gonna break
through that no matter what it takes I
needed to reach dead core that vision
that I had of being a world champion
think big because then you're gonna get
big then you're gonna go and achieve big
things that is the most important thing
you know we don't achieve big things by
accident so shoot for the top shoot for
the sky further you know of for the
stars all of those liabilities that they
talked about started turning into assets
when it had Conan the Barbarian the
director came to me and he said if we
wouldn't have you we would have to build
one and then Terminator the director
said I couldn't imagine to have anyone
play determinated it wouldn't have an
accent and they wouldn't have your body
I cannot imagine the line I'll be back
with a normal American accent it works
so perfectly that you have this German
accent so all of those things that they
say the liabilities became an asset the
moment as moment went on they grew and
grew and I went from one movie to the
next so they're making more and more
money and then an aunt ended up being
the highest-paid actor with 30 million
dollars and Terminator 3 that must be
the same bar bodybuilding intention
Hogan
he came on to be a young son Thomas in
my [ __ ] get honoured one strives they
kick neither the fountain Elton house
this way I getting it C average my
father he said this is an embarrassment
to me and was stumping all over me the
other thing is is that you got to work
your butt off if you think that you're
gonna go and accomplish something really
special and be the best in anything in
the world and you think you can do it
without working you make a big mistake
because no matter what I did if it was a
body building or an acting or if it is
in a political arena it always took a
lot a lot of work and you got a boot out
and you got the you know sometimes make
a lot of sacrifices notice if you're not
willing to work hard forget about it so
there's another rule that is very
important use your power of potential
and make this nation in this world a
better place
it worked for this immigrant that came
over here to this country with $20 in
the pocket and I know and I guarantee it
will work for you too I say they wanted
to get into acting people said no you
have an accent and you have a party that
is too big and you name no one can
pronounce be realistic it's the 70s day
Dustin Hoffman he's the Big Shot Al
Pacino little guys Woody Allen said
simple even when I ran for governor
this is are you kidding me I mean he can
never win give it up well I didn't pay
any attention because any myself what
did I do when they said you can't go to
German you can't compete in a junior mr.
Europe that I did not listen to the no I
went and it worked out
and I used that editor as a blueprint to
the rest of my life
don't be afraid to fail because if
you're afraid to fail then you're always
holding yourself back because you're
afraid that if you go all out you may
fail well in weightlifting we learned it
very quickly the only way you could
break a record is if you're willing to
fail that's when you put on more weight
you try it sometimes you maybe don't you
would not be able to lift it we just
happened to me many times but eventually
when you train hard enough you will lift
it so don't be afraid to failure I mean
how far can you fall in Austria kids
were conditioned avowal parents have but
unlike other kids around me I was very
determined that I have to get out of
there and then one day I saw the cup of
a magazine of reg Park then it says how
mr. universe became Hercules I opened up
this magazine and the red fluid and
there was the whole plan lay down
ask yourself Arnold what is it about you
that is so different why are you the
only one that sees it so clearly the
score going the America winning the Mr
Universe contest and getting into movies
and making millions of dollars no one
else talks about this amount yes is it
real is it just a crazy fantasy but wait
a minute Bridge Park did it then it's
possible Arnold
focus the key thing is to be focused
visualize your goal and I saw myself
standing up then the stage just like
Ridge Park and it became more and more
clear Arnold you've got to go that just
shows you again so much for it can't be
done this is why I try to tell you
anything and everything can be done if
you can visualize it and if you believe
in yourself it was the same thing again
when I ran for governor you can imagine
when I went on at the night show and I
announced that I'm gonna run for
governor of the great state of
California people came to me afterwards
says you're crazy you don't announce
something like this under Tonight Show
you have an official press conference at
the State Capitol plus you don't start
the governorship you go start first
mayor of each state senator and I said I
don't want to be senator I don't want to
be mayor I want to be governor don't you
understand that well the rest is history
I won in 2003 and they won also in 2006
let me tell you you're going to find the
naysayers in every turn that you make
don't listen
just visualize your goal know exactly
where you want to go trust yourself
get out there and Brooke like hell and
break some of the rules and never ever
be afraid of failure thank you guys so
much for watching I made this video
because Daniel Grantham asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile and you want to see a
top 10 list of leave their name in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do for you now Arnold likes to talk a
lot about how important it is to have a
clear goal to set out and achieve for
yourself so my question of the day for
you today is what is your clear goal
what is a clear goal that you you are
trying to work towards to build that
life and that business for yourself
leave it in the comments I'd love to
hear from you and of course if you liked
this video you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the newsletter
into the channel and I hope to again see
you tomorrow morning for another shot of
entrepreneurship to kick start your day
thank you for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon